[Musique]
ces messieurs
je l'immense honneur de vous présenter
le huitième merveille du monde
le cerf est l'unique
plus
le
cube abonnés
sapere
tué presque un vrai gars en a
tourne toi que je regarde si tout va
bien je serai à la maison et quand tu
reviendras pinocchio pour les rues tout
seul sans une conscience vous imaginez
les menaces qui pèsent sur lui je
n'aimerais pas voir ça sur ma roue sur
toute personne qui n'est pas personnes
en vie de plus de personnes je vais être
un vrai garçon pourquoi diable veux tu
être vrai alors que tu peux être
célèbre
[Musique]
depuis huit ans le petit devrait être
entre
[Musique]
tu seras plus marionnettes envoie
garantie sur facture
[Musique]
non
pinocchio
soit preuve
général
et digne de confiance
tu seras jamais monfreid petit garçon
[Musique]
mensonge peut vraiment transformé
quelqu'un qu'est ce qui se passe du min
on dirait de la magie féerique à vue de
nez ça y ressemble bien